[Música]
Pues estamos listos para hablar de
economía aquí en directo América ya está
con nosotros en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches Gracias por
acompañarnos hoy y comenzamos hablando
de la eurozona porque Bruselas cree que
equivocó o esquivó digamos lo mejor esa
recesión económica que estaban esperando
Bueno hablamos del descenso de los
precios de la energía en los últimos
meses y también el buen comportamiento
del mercado laboral europeo derivaron en
un cierto pero leve crecimiento
económico que fue sorpresivo en la
segunda mitad del 2022 la comisión
aseguró que el crecimiento económico en
los 20 países que utilizan el euro
probablemente será del 0,9% este año en
lugar del 0,3% que habían previsto en
noviembre pasado la zona de la moneda
única evitará Por poco la recesión
técnica que la comisión ya prohibía hace
tres meses y esto por el crecimiento de
los últimos tres meses de 2022 que fue
del 0,1%
mezcal la inflación alcanzó máximos
históricos del 10,6% en octubre pasado
debido a la subida de los precios de la
energía y los alimentos que fue
provocada por supuesto por la invasión
rusa de Ucrania pero los precios bajarán
al 5,6% este año y el 2,5% en 2024 la
comisión afirma que la demanda exterior
también podría resultar más robusta tras
la reapertura de China Pero esto
inclusive es un arma doble filo porque
también podría alimentar la inflación
mundial según las previsiones todos los
estados miembros de la Unión Europea
crecerán este año menos Suecia que se
contraerá un 0,8% Bueno aunque ustedes
parezca extraño hay un impacto
particular entre el Super Bowl del 2023
y los cultivos de aguacate en México sin
duda alguna y bueno casi todos los años
sucede este fenómeno productores de
aguacate de Jalisco al oeste de México
enviaron por primera vez en seis años al
menos Diez mil toneladas de aguacates
hacia Estados Unidos el envío Busca
satisfacer demanda de este fruto entre
los aficionados del Super Bowl la máxima
fiesta del fútbol americano realizado
este domingo la exportación de las diez
mil toneladas de aguacate desde Jalisco
representa un 8% de las 130,000
toneladas que serán exportadas a nivel
nacional el volumen restante de Santiago
provienen de granjas y empacadores de
Michoacán según la asociación de
productores y empacadores exportadores
de aguacate de México Michoacán y
Jalisco son los dos únicos estados
autorizados por el Departamento de
agricultura de los Estados Unidos para
exportar a dicho país México suministra
alrededor del 92% de las importaciones
estadounidenses de aguacate con un valor
de más de 13 mil millones de dólares al
año pues Estos son beneficios para los
agricultores el Michoacán y en Jalisco
entonces hablemos ahora de San Valentín
que es una de las primeras celebraciones
del año y traerá beneficios a la región
de América Latina Pese a que aquí no se
celebra tanto así es bueno siendo
grandes productores de flores países
como Colombia Ecuador y Guatemala
lideran la lista la expectativa de los
productores colombianos por ejemplo para
2023 es producir 58 mil toneladas unos
800 millones de tallos Y aunque su
principal mercado es Estados Unidos las
flores colombianas están en más de 100
países pero San Valentín representa el
15% del total de las ventas anuales en
Colombia en Ecuador Expo flores reportó
un incremento de los envíos del 5,4% del
volumen total de toneladas exportadas
eso entre el 10 de enero de este año y
el 8 de febrero Ecuador Es el segundo
exportador a nivel mundial Mientras
tanto Guatemala espera exportar unos 8
millones de detalles en el contexto de
San Valentín allí las asociaciones
esperan crecer un 5% en las
exportaciones pasamos ahora a hablar del
sector Automotriz Jorge hablemos de
Toyota la compañía japonesa va a enfocar
su producción de vehículos eléctricos
así lo anunció kojito asumir a la
presidencia el primero de abril el grupo
automovilístico Toyota se va a centrar
en la electrificación y el desarrollo de
vehículos inteligentes y también la
diversificación la empresa aumentará su
oferta de vehículos eléctricos de
batería centrándose en su marca de lujo
Lexus y mantendrá su objetivo anterior
de vender 3,5 millones de vehículos
eléctricos de batería para el año 2030
Jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía a
continuación aquí en directo América
hablamos de su país Nicaragua en el
debate a continuación